so here's the thing we have entered a
time in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
where literally anything is possible
you've heard me say this before but I
truly mean it and anything really is
possible we're about to dive deep into
the Multiverse in Phase five where
they're going to show us that if you can
think of it if you can imagine it it is
really possible including the return of
Robert Downey Jr as Iron Man and the
return of Scarlett Johansson as Black
Widow now of course with Avengers Secret
Wars coming up in the next few years
really anything is possible however
these new reports actually state that
Robert Downey Jr and Scarlett Johansson
are going to be returning in projects
before Secret Wars and they're not going
to be in the King Dynasty instead Robert
Downey Jr is said to be returning in
armor Wars and Scarlett Johansson is
rumored to be coming back during the
Thunderbolts now with Scarlett Johansson
we had heard in the past that she's
actually on board to direct a Marvel
movie and Marvel is going to give her a
movie to direct however we could have
been a little bit mistaken about that
and she could simply be returning in
another film The Thunderbolts the only
question is how exactly with these two
movies it doesn't look like they're
going to be exploring the Multiverse too
much in fact it seems like we pretty
much know a decent amount about both of
the plots for both of these projects and
the Multiverse really isn't that
involved so how exactly will these two
return to their iconic characters
without undoing their sacrifices because
as weird as it sounds there is a reason
these two characters are dead these two
characters in the MCU Iron Man and Black
Widow sacrifice their own lives to save
the universe so their deaths and their
sacrifices actually mean something so
how can you bring them back without
undoing that well there are a couple of
different ways for each of them to
return that actually makes sense and
would fit in the story rather than just
throwing them in to throw them in these
couple of ways they could put them in
both films would make sense storytelling
wise so how exactly are they going to
return well let's talk about Robert
Downey Jr first now first things first
if you are not aware armor Wars with Don
Cheadle is being made into a movie and
based off of what Marvel Studios has
said and Don Cheadle has said the story
was kind of too big to be a Disney Plus
show which it was originally going to be
so now it's going to be a big movie with
a big budget luckily for us and luckily
for the movie because if this report is
true coming from my time to shine hello
today they'll need some of that to bring
Robert Downey Jr back because one way
that Robert Downey Jr could be returning
as Tony Stark slash Iron Man himself is
the one that makes the most sense and
that is for him to return as AI this
idea is pretty easy to grasp considering
the fact that armor Wars is actually
going to be about what happens when Iron
Man Tony Stark technology falls into the
wrong hands so even if Robert Downey Jr
doesn't return he's still going to kind
of have a pretty big presence in this
movie after all Roadie is still going to
be rocking the war machine armor which
of course was given to him by Tony Stark
then he's going to be dealing with Iron
Man Tech that is in the wrong hands
however according to a report from The
Insider my time to shine hello who has
been extremely accurate with her Scoops
Robert Downey Jr is returning and she
says so with quite confidence might I
add she said Robert Downey Jr is back
baby for Secret Wars for sure and
there's been some talks for Cameo and
armor Wars so as far as returning in
armor Wars goes AI makes perfect sense
however that's not the route I believe
they'll go that would probably require
Robert Downey Jr to kind of stay on
board for a little bit something that I
definitely don't think he wants to do
could he pop up for a cameo absolutely
but not come back in any type of main
role or play any type of main AI so the
other option is flashbacks slash old
video messages and that includes some
type of recorded projectile message like
we saw him do for Morgan at the end of
Avengers end game I'm assuming Tony
Stark left quite a lot to Roadie
specifically probably a lot of his Iron
Man stuff in fact I wouldn't be
surprised at all if Tony Stark left him
his entire personal garage different
Iron Man suits all of the equipment his
cars all of that stuff that would be a
great gift to his best friend who
happens to use an Iron Man suit so if
this scenario comes to fruition it would
make sense that Tony Stark left him some
sort of a message or perhaps Roadie
simply goes through old messages that
show Tony Stark talking to him I think
that if we're going to get a cameo for
Robert Downey Jr this is most likely
what we're going to get an old recording
of something or a flashback of a time
that we didn't see on screen before in
the MCU of him and Rody simply walking
and talking as friends or talking
business either way it will be set in
the past and Robert Downey Jr's Iron Man
isn't going to be resurrected which is a
good thing yes it would be nice to have
him return as Iron Man in the MCU but
again it would undo everything that he's
done and the same kind of goes for Black
Widow however there is a way for her to
actually return and still be alive it's
very controversial but you all have to
let me know what you think but first a
big thank you to wonder for sponsoring
this video now recently I'm sure you've
seen all of these people online posting
art made by Ai and wonder is an app that
makes it easy to turn your words into
digital art there's been some really
cool work created by Ai and wonder makes
it really easy to do all you have to do
to turn your words into mesmerizing
Digital Arts is enter a prompt pick an
art style and watch Wonder bring your
idea to life in seconds describe to
wonder what you wanted to paint such as
life under the sea or shattered rainbow
then pick a style and hit create and you
can get really creative with this app
for example I tried a cat as a person
scuba diving and this is what it came up
with and of course I had to try some
Marvel things so I tried Spider-Man
underwater and of course I had to try
Tom Cruise as Iron Man I even typed in
Iron Man if he was painted by Van Gogh
so click the link to download wonder and
get a free trial of the premium version
to put your creativity to the test
premium includes 20 Styles it's faster
it's unlimited art and there are no ads
again you can download Wonder right here
by clicking this link and get a free
trial of the premium version to put your
creativity to the test so with black
widow more so than Iron Man there is
actually an option to bring her back to
life in the MCU this is kind of possible
for Iron Man as well but I really doubt
it but again it is to actually bring her
back to life as a character and the way
to do that is to say that she was a
scroll the entire time now before you
jump off the deep end and freak out I'm
just gonna go ahead and stop you there
and tell you that I don't think this is
going to happen although it definitely
could secret invasion is coming out
before the Thunderbolts movie and like I
mentioned in a previous video which
we'll have Linked In the pinned comment
Secret Wars could change the entirety of
the MCU as we know it by saying that
some of our heroes that we've known and
loved were actually scroll now I'm
assuming they won't do this too much
because it's kind of a big slap in the
face however if they want to show big
consequences of the scroll and how big
of a threat they are them impersonating
other Heroes is a a great way to show it
and this did happen in the comics and
was a huge storyline so they could say
much like how Talos impersonated Nick
Fury somebody else was kind of
impersonating Black Widow however I
don't think it's plausible and if they
did decide to do it it would indeed be a
huge slap in the face to Marvel fans the
reason is is because of course she
sacrificed herself for the Soul Stone
which means Clint technically sacrificed
somebody he loved in order to get the
stone now you can argue that even if it
was a scroll who was trying to do good
Clint could have loved her or at least
thought he loved her however I'm
assuming that Red Skull and the Soul
Stone knew since they don't just accept
anybody I'm assuming they're going to
know if it's actually Black Widow the
actual person that Hawkeye loved or a
scroll so if they did this and they
brought her back this way by saying that
oh the one that died was actually a
scroll it's just a huge problem and they
absolutely should not do it although
they could and like I said they could
also do that for Iron Man as well
although it would be a pretty big screw
you and it would undo the biggest movie
of all time which they're never going to
do so this most likely isn't going to
happen however it is an option but of
course the most likely scenario for both
Robert Downey Jr to return and Scarlett
Johansson to return is in some type of a
flashback or recorded message since
Scarlett Johansson is rumored to show up
in the Thunderbolts movie We're assuming
that she is showing up because of her
sister Yelena bolova who is going to be
a part of the Thunderbolts team we also
know that Elena Bulova is going to be
the New Black Widow of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe taking over the
mantle of her sister plus not to mention
she's going to have a bone to pick with
Val Valentina Allegra de Fontaine a
person who she works for who told her
that her sister's death was caused by
Hawkeye which led her down a path of
going to kill Hawkeye however Hawkeye
told her the truth which is going to
lead Yelena back to Valentina who she
still works for at least for now and
she's going to be asking a lot of
questions and these are going to be
about her sister Natasha Romanoff Black
Widow so when this happens I'm assuming
we're going to see some flashbacks we
could see some new pictures of her that
we never saw before or some new videos
of Yelena and black widow together again
which we never saw before basically a
new scene that would require Scarlett
Johansson to come film new scenes the
same thing goes for Robert Downey Jr so
these are the two most likely ways that
both Robert Downey Jr and Scarlett
Johansson could return to play their
legendary and iconic characters of Iron
Man Tony Stark and black widow Natasha
Romanov before Secret Wars keep that in
mind because for Secret Wars it's pretty
easy for them to return as variants
that's simple just say they're from a
different universe and they look exactly
like the same variant from Earth 616.
remember some variants do look the same
although some do look different we've
seen the same variants of Wanda and
Doctor Strange look the same however
we've seen Spider-Man variants look
different and we've seen a lot of Loki
variants look different as well so for
Secret Wars I would fully we expect to
see Robert Downey Jr and Scarlett
Johansson return simply playing variants
of themselves from other universes but
let us know what you think about these
theories in the comments down below and
what do you think about the two of them
returning do you have an idea of your
own of how they could come back let us
know in the comments down below and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news be sure to follow us
on Twitter and Instagram and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf